truly shocking revelation from a lawsuit
that has been filed remember that entire
set rich conspiracy theory the one where
some on the right and some on the left
were suggesting that the death of DN C
aid Seth rich was part of a cover-up of
some kind that Seth rich was really the
source for the WikiLeaks in terms of all
those DN C emails at the peak of the
presidential campaign that Julian
Assange WikiLeaks released the right
like bit because it made it look like
Trump Russia collusion was less likely
the left likes it I honestly don't know
why but I think it has something to do
with denying Trump Russia collusion
helps blame the DNC and Hillary for
Hillary's loss and maybe demonstrates in
their mind that Bernie would have won or
something like that anyway FoxNews ran
with the story they breathe the ton of
life into it and it ended up getting
picked up by lots of conspiracy types on
the left and right mostly on the
internet and according to a lawsuit
that's been filed by rod wheeler a long
time paid contributor to Fox News Fox
News was working with the White House to
concoct the set rich conspiracy theory
wheeler claims in his lawsuit that Fox
News was working with this Trump
supporter who wanted to deflect the
attention away from the growing Trump
Russia scandal the story first aired in
May on Fox News it was retracted by Fox
News a week later but the damage had
already been done and Fox News really
took no action in response to what even
they admitted was a story that did not
meet their own journalistic standards
the lawsuit claims that Fox News made up
quotes out of thin air the lawsuit says
that Trump supporter IDI Bukowski
offered to pay rod wheeler to
investigate the death of Seth rich and
according to the lawsuit Bukowski and
wheeler met at the White House with Sean
Spicer to talk about what they were
finding out and the first page of the
lawsuit has quotes it quotes a voicemail
it quotes a text message from Bukowski
boasting that Donald Trump himself had
reviewed drafts of the fox news story
right before it was published and even
Sean Spicer NPR is all over the story
even Sean Spicer admits
that the meeting took place in the Oval
Office but he says the meeting was
merely a favor to Buttowski that Spicer
wasn't personally aware of any contact
with the president and Bukowski later
told NPR that he was kidding about the
contact with Trump sort of a weird thing
to joke about but okay but the thing is
there's lots of really specific things
in the lawsuit about contact with the
White House and Trump on May 14 36 hours
before Fox News's story appeared
Bukowski left a voicemail for wheeler
saying we have the full attention of the
White House on this and tomorrow let's
close this deal whatever we've got to do
Bukowski also texted wheeler saying not
to add any more pressure but the
president just read the article he wants
the article out immediately it's now all
up to you this week Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the new White House press
secretary was asked about it she said
quote the president had no knowledge of
the story and it's completely untrue
that he and the White House were
involved Huckabee Sanders also added at
the end of the briefing that she's not
sure whether Trump believes that Seth
rich is the leaker of the emails to
WikiLeaks it will be very interesting to
see how this plays out in court
considering that wheeler has the
receipts write text call logs etc which
prove that his quotes in the story were
fabricated but most of the story is
still here say between Bukowski and
wheeler and it would not be surprising
that the White House might have used Fox
News strategically as a mouthpiece to
create distractions from Trump Russia
they've done that many times before that
part would not be a shock yeah and that
Trump approved it too and you know that
would be incredibly surprising to me
because Trump always goes after fake
news and poorly sourced articles I mean
horse now would mean that he wasn't
being ideologically consistent which
would be stunning that would be a major
revelation the left some of these
elements of the left that really like
the Seth rich story they're already
saying the lawsuit is part of the
conspiracy to make Hillary look good I
read the entire NPR story it is very
very solid reporting and I don't know
why this toxic element of the lack
really likes the Seth rich thing do you
really need
Seth rich to have
killed in a cover-up in order to
validate Bernie Sanders I don't believe
the nonsense conspiracy but I supported
Bernie and I don't see how Bernie's
candidacy is any less valid if Seth rich
isn't the leaker of the DNC weeks like I
just don't get the connection I don't
know why they need that in order to
validate Bernie
especially when you have Seth Rich's
family saying enough of this and you
even have like Fox News retracting the
story I mean how much more than that you
want they want a lot more they will not
believe it until they get a lot more and
even that would just be proof that the
entire thing is being controlled by the
deep state or the Illuminati or the
trilateral commission I don't know pick
your poison today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like an
an eyeglass or the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial com forward slash TDP
s